qu'est ce qui compte pour toi
quand as tu été le plus heureux montrent
un business à partir de cette sensation
quelle mouche vous viennent à l'esprit
quand je vous dis espace de travail en
coin bureau
mahb le moche et au mauvais éclairage
moore
tout à fait d'accord
l'avenir il est en pleine métamorphose
on vend une expérience
il faut qu'on trouve un nom wii ou et
livre i dream works
s'ils gagnent ces combats c'est
l'intelligence c'est le foie
vous n'êtes pas assez fou je peux l'être
je peux l'être
[Rires]
ce qu'adam et sérieux je serai pas avec
l'uci ne l'était pas la femme elle
travaille là-bas l'aide à manifester des
jours on est parti pour perdre plus de
400 millions de dollars sa famille j'ai
pas dit on s'attend je me sens à peu
près bien je suis à toi de leur montrer
hockey tresquois tweed super dans là
et tu t'inquiètes il de surface
êtes vous une franc tireuse ou une muse
je suis une muse parlez-moi de vos
ambitions je dois avouer que j'ai
ensuite dans vanity fair vanity fair
n'est pas pour les mus
par ce que je veux changer ma réponse
je voulais que vous rencontriez le
légendaire adam newman ainsi que sa
femme j'essuie s'achève démarré au long
des espaces de bureaux et on se comporte
comme si on changeait le monde ils vont
vous lâchez vous allez faire couler le
navire
c'est un point 9 milliards de pertes
rien n'est plus important que nous j'ai
la responsabilité de voir plus grand je
suis la poule aux oeufs d'or si vous
arrivez à vous en rendre compte qu'ils
n'auraient rien pu faire sans moi
on part en guerre
si on fait ça tous les deux on va tout
changer on va tout changer
en
[Musique]
proposant une droite décomplexée
j'ai senti qu'il fallait des hommes
politiques qui disent tout haut ce que
les gens pensent tous bonjour chers amis
bonjour connard un
talent à famars d'emmerder les français
alors chers collègues c'est impossible
ou détruire une forêt millénaire pour
tous serait un village loisirs danse et
noah s'amusait plus avec l'ancien
champion matic trouve ça rigolo mireille
dans ce projet n'est 55 boutiques et les
eaux des cinq piscines à vagues seront
recyclés pour l'arrosage des de golf est
ce qu'on voulait faire plus écolo que ça
demain vous votez pour moi longtemps
même si j'étais pour par convaincre les
autres va vous présenter la gauche avoue
mangent dans la main
[Musique]
dix écoles et tous les deux ensemble
colère l'un derrière l'autre
vous m'avez viola neu neu el hout a
collé gauche droite gauche droite haut
risque
la peur elle va changer quand on
t'envoie il faut que vous compreniez que
vous voulez passer de bipèdes ou
quadrupèdes
vous baissez votre foi que devant
n'importe quel oubli est un bel exemple
angers - est-ce qu'on a vidéosurveillées
les vaches en somme
mais gillet jour les antilles vague les
anti viande c'est vraiment devenu
intenable
un fait la honte c'est pas qu'on nous
voit comme ça ford a fait
si on parlait plus des migrateurs que
des migrants des campagnes électorales
moins pourri
moi je vais changer je commence à me
plaire de plus en plus toi
[Musique]
tens légèrement ouvert comme ça appuie
sur la droite légèrement aussi et
[Musique]
le cherche à cochon truffier
quelqu'un me la voler
je ne comprends pas dit lui qui tu es
vous avez fait le bon choix
en vous retirant dans ces bois
il n'y a plus rien pour vous ici il n'ya
pas grand chose pour beaucoup d'entre
nous
payez-vous un nouveau cochon
à quoi qu'ils pensent
je me rappelle
chaque plat que j'ai cuisiné
je me rappelle chaque personne que j'ai
servi
vous vivez pour eux
et ils ne vous voient même pas
vous ne vous voyez même pas vous même
[Musique]
dans une vie à très peu de chose qui
compte vraiment
[Musique]
qui à mon cochon
il est temps qu'on fasse nos bagages et
qu'on laisse notre trace dans ce monde
liberté des hommes au sol
non ces imbéciles sont retournés dans le
monde souterrain
c'est à moi qu'on reprend que le faire
de mauvaise foi
le monde souterrain
cet endroit est le plus dangereux au
monde
attends une minute tu pourrais répéter
j'allume du move coincés dans leurs
règles on sait que vous êtes fatigué ce
qui vous amène sur mon territoire on est
revenu ici pour vivre une aventure pour
comme toi
commence à me demander de ces petites
folies terre c'est sûr que c'est le bon
moment puisque c'est la question
il est contré
la seule canicule tu peux nous en dire
un peu plus sur ton équipe de
super-héros
concerne je n'emploie pas le terme super
héros
mais je ne vous interdis pas de
l'utiliser
[Musique]
j'adore les retrouvailles familiales
le 15 mai
[Musique]
pouah
charmant
[Musique]
car
non
[Musique]
oui
à
qu'est ce que vous faites ici
[ __ ]
[Musique]
pourquoi au fait
ton père et toi vous habitez ou on est
en vacances dans une grande maison près
de l'eau au milieu de nulle part et
aussi ma mère avec nous mais ils
s'entendent pas toujours il te maltraite
non ça va tu t'es fait un petit ami dans
le coin ferme
[Applaudissements]
tu l'as pas trouvé étrange ce vieux non
pas du tout
j'arrive pas à l'ouvrir tape à la clé
pas de cette porte celle où
[Musique]
est ce que je peux vous ai dit non je
m'appelle isaac je suis venu vous
inviter à dîner ce soir avec votre mari
et anna on a apporté ce qu'il faut pour
cuisiner ici c'est comme ça que ça se
passe dans le bayou alors est-ce qu'on
peut rentrer entre huy entrée
pour cette phrase sur meetic est celle
que vous m'avez écrite vous vouliez me
dire quoi
le diable a tout le temps les yeux rivés
sur nous
certains la vita entrer d'autres non
ne prenez pas mal mais je ne crois pas
au diable mais lui croit en vous
ah non tu saigne du nez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe je veux qu'il
parte il ne faut pas fuir la vérité vous
en faites pas
les gens honnêtes n'ont rien à craindre
vous êtes un geek
tu es né poussière et tu redeviendras
poussière
pas la peine d'avoir peur je ne suis pas
le croquemitaine
[Musique]
s'il te plaît oui oui
c'est un paradis
te voilà
plus éblouissante que jamais mon dieu tu
la gastro mille tonnes
j'ai les moyens de vous aider
financièrement je peux très bien
m'occuper nom n'en fait pas une question
d'ego
c'était jumeaux frais et avec un
merveilleux petit garçon s'était jumeaux
je les ai vus tu me manques je le sais
tu fais ça laissait besoin de mon bébé
j'ai peur
chérie chéri narré par google
elle ne va pas bien on sait qu'elle n'a
pas très bien
pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça
comment tout ça
il n'avait fait aucune crise depuis
trois ans elle avait arrêté son
traitement comment vous pouviez ne pas
savoir oh c'est moi rappelle moi s'il te
plaît
qu'est ce qui se passe ou ce qu'ils sont
à l'eau
elle a pris les passeports elle a très
bien pu quitter le pays avec mon fils je
vais appeler la police pour faire quoi
au juste
cette fan vous l'avais vu
j'en sais rien
sans connaître les faits on aura aucune
réponse j'ai besoin de savoir comment
c'est arrivé vous êtes en état de choc
vous devez vous ressaisir
les faits où est votre mère et j'ai vu
quelqu'un qui me suivait
c'est plus le moment de jouer mais pas
en train de jouer oui
c'est ça que vous voulez qu'elle soit
interne et pour le restant de ses jours
[Musique]